foreign
you know we're getting married I wanted
to say no I knew that it wasn't right
which has led to kind of one foot in one
foot out don't BS me like why is she the
wrong person I've always been attracted
to other women more than her
yo yo this is John with the Dr John
Maloney show the greatest mental health
and marriage imperiting podcast that's
ever existed ever history of time
humanity and even before that
so glad that you're joining us if you
want to be on this show if you want to
be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 or go to
johnbaloney.com ask a-s-k fill out the
form and we will uh get you on the show
cannot wait please don't forget hit the
Subscribe button or the like button or
whatever buttons are telling you to push
now
um so this shows up in your feed and
your five star reviews are super super
um
I'm grateful for him I'll say it that
way I'm really really grateful all right
let's go out to Anna in Queens New York
what's up Anna
Anna are you there I'm here can you hear
me yeah what's up I'm sorry I'm Hi how
are you oh don't be sorry you're up to
you you're good it's an honor to talk to
you how are you
I am so nervous right now I'm like
shaking are you kid Anna seriously Have
you listened to the show
oh my God like you wouldn't believe I
watched your YouTube videos all the time
so it's really weird to just hear your
voice okay but listen you know I'm not
very good at this you have nothing to be
nervous about at all I assure you
um so what's up how can I help
okay so
um in preparation for this call uh
because I know
I had to ramble when I'm super nervous I
wrote everything down so I'm just gonna
read off like a little script here yes
you are a saint good for you I I need to
take lessons from you on how to just be
a better human so okay go for it okay so
my question is uh when facing arguments
or disagreements in a relationship how
can I change my mindsets from a me
versus you mentality to an US versus the
problem so um I wrote out some like
background
so my boyfriend and I have been together
for almost two years and we moved in
together back in June of last year from
the beginning we were very open and
honest about what we wanted out of our
relationship we shared our values and
thoughts on what we wanted our futures
to look like and found that we wanted
the same thing he's kind thoughtful a
super dork and all around hilarious and
I just love him to pieces he's actually
the reason how I became a listener of
your show he found Dave Ramsey in an
attempt to help me figure out how to pay
off my debt and if my calculations are
accurate I should be debt free by the
end of this year way to go very cool
thank you he has been such a rock and
support system throughout this
tumultuous Journey making sure to wipe
my tears away when I've reached my limit
to offer me advice and words of
encouragement when I need a most and
truly walking beside me every step of
the way
when it comes to my part in our
relationship I truly struggle with
voicing my needs especially when it
comes to arguments what I try to say
comes out entirely wrong and actually
makes the argument much worse because it
starts with me wanting to present why
I'm feeling upset but the way I
communicate it ends up hurting him and
escalating the situation
stop right there I want to dig in real
quick where does it
where does that come from
when when was it communicated to you
that your needs didn't matter
oh like essentially my entire life okay
yeah and
so I want you imagine you um you're in
Queens right so imagine
um you left queens and just were dropped
into Mexico City
okay everyone's speaking Spanish
it would be really frustrating because
you you you're trying to communicate
you're trying to be good human you're
trying just to get some food you're
trying to get some like take care of
your like leaky pipe in your apartment
but you don't speak Spanish and so
you're learning Spanish and you're
practicing and you're trying you're
going to stumble through it and you're
gonna look up in two or three years
later you're gonna be
almost fluent right because you've been
practicing
think of expressing your needs like that
okay so just like more practice it's
being very gentle with yourself
okay and saying one of your needs out
loud to your boyfriend which is I'm
gonna say this probably the wrong way is
now a good time
and so he can go okay and if you if you
tell him hey I'm trying to learn how to
express my needs Express what I need
and he may need to practice on hearing
somebody else's needs because he may
have grown up in a home where his job
was to make sure everybody was okay
and if somebody has a need then his body
responds as you're failing and mom's
gonna get pissed and rip the cabinets
off the wall
and you see how couples do this dance
together where I don't really know how
to say my needs and I bottle them up
bottom up and then you just explode as a
good New Yorker and then he is a
peacekeeper I just got to make sure Dad
doesn't get pissed and Mom doesn't drink
too much and I gotta gotta and then all
sudden he gets this explosion and he
shuts down and now we're in this
loop-de-loopy loop-de-loop is that fair
yeah no sir
um uh should I should I continue yeah of
course continue yeah yeah
um so uh the original issue gets pushed
and then the argument is no longer about
the issue I presented but more of how
I'm hurtful and careless with my words
so this has been an ongoing pattern in
our arguments and in our most recent
argument he said that he feels I
approach issues with the mentality that
it's me against him and he often feels
like I'm attacking him when he's trying
his best in our relationship and when I
thought about it I realized he was right
are you do you attack him
so my perspective is like so I never
yell I never curse you know I don't I
don't come off aggressive but
um when I'm upset you can like taste it
in the air you know like I'm assuming
right and I just get very quiet and so
he'll like he'll very gently come over
and be like hey are you okay or do you
want to talk about it and then I'll just
very like calmly say you know I'm
feeling this because of you know you're
doing this or you're not doing this and
I would appreciate if you did that but
then he's like you don't necessarily
just because you're speaking calmly to
me doesn't mean that your words are oh
dude that's an old yeah that is an old
uh
um
that's an old male trick
that where you become this radioactive
Center my wife calls it Sunday afternoon
dad like this like just sitting on the
couch in this pulsing energy and anybody
who's like hey what's wrong and you're
like nothing why are you always
bothering me and Hassle and all of a
sudden it's like whoa right you said
something really really important
you said when he asks you hey what's
wrong you said you're making me feel dot
dot
and I call bullcrap on that
you are choosing
to feel XYZ
and that's the real question why are you
why is your body shutting you down why
is it feelings are like are like um sign
the road signs why is your body telling
you exit here
why is your body telling you slow down
and go one mile an hour because there's
a wreck ahead
why is it telling you that that's it's
the gosh whenever someone says this word
I roll my eyes but it's so true that's
mindfulness
why is my but it's being curious why is
my body so mad right now because that
guy loves me
we're on the same team I really wish
he'd pick a socks up
so stupid they don't pick a socks up but
I know he loves me
why is my body responding as though
we're breaking up and this is it and he
slept with my best friend like you see
what I'm saying like it just gears up
that's where
you take ownership of how your body's
responding to a situation and then from
that
you you might have some very very very
real needs
you are absolutely disrespecting me you
are abusing me you are in the same way
you can by the way you can control the
house not by yelling not by swearing but
just being this this gravitational pull
of all joy and happiness
he can
hide his frustration and and
disappointment and anger and shame with
a big old smiley face and I'm bringing
you your cup of coffee just like you
like it he can hide there too
oh my God that's actually pretty pretty
fine because he he does say that
um when we had this our most recent
argument he did mention that like the
things that you're upset about he's like
they aggravate me too because you do
them as well but I choose to look at the
bigger picture right like I love this
woman you know I see a future together
we're going to get married like this is
the one for me and she's going through a
lot right now like I work two jobs you
know because of being on this debt-free
journey and everything so I'm constantly
busy and tired and he's like I can
Overlook like if she leaves her teacup
on the table but if I do it it's a whole
thing so he really wishes that I could
just take a step back and just look at
everything that we have and every like
you know all the love that we have in
this house and you know how much we love
each other and support one another and
just think like you know that's enough
like he's and not to not to like he's
not saying that my needs are not
important you know but he's like and
he's more than happy to help meet my
needs but he would really appreciate it
if at first I just kind of looked took a
step back and looked at everything and
see how I feel after
I take that would you like that that
sounds like a much more peaceful way of
living
100 but it's
it's something happens like I just like
I see red yeah and I'm not violent
I'm not violent but I'll kill him to
death so here's what I want you to do
okay two things
um is there a is there a cultural divide
here y'all y'all have different
um racial ethnic backgrounds yeah yeah
okay
um this is super common too where
there's a I don't say a cultural
mismatch because it makes it sound like
it's it's dysfunctional but there is
just here's the way we talk in our house
right um I was talking to the the Great
Master therapist Terry reel Terence real
and
um I was asking about yelling because I
I've just come to believe that yelling
is abusive and he in his I think his
example was
it is unless you're a family in New
Jersey and that's the way you talk to
each like it's just that ah shut up and
it's it's a it's part of the culture
right or I grew up in Texas and my
friends who were first gen Mexican
Americans who very different approach to
like hey there's an issue here I got
real stoic and quiet and they may get
fill in the blank right so I think
there's a call out the cultural mismatch
there or hey I'm not you're gonna love
me what what are what is the different
um ethnic backgrounds
um he's Asian okay
I'm
this is gonna be spectacular spectacular
right so I could make all the
generalizations here right that I
learned in grad school I won't do that
but
ask yourself has he been trained to
respond in in way acts and you've been
trained to respond in way why okay and
there may be a mix match there so you
may be you may be swimming more Upstream
than you think it may not be that you're
broken it may be that the way you were
trained to engage in an issue
is was really helpful in this context
we're gonna have to create new contacts
together in this new relationship okay
so that's number one number two on a
very practical skill here's what I want
you to do this is going to cost you
probably 79 cents are you ready for this
investment
okay you may have to work a third job to
pull this one off but we can do it okay
I want you to go down to a corner market
like CVS or Walgreens or something like
that once you get a deck of
um
I want you just to get a package of uh
note cards okay
I've got a hard writing deadline and
I've been up
uh into the mornings for the last two
weeks and my words aren't coming so I
want you to get a pack of note cards
and when you get mad
when you see a quote-unquote problem
I want you to pull out one of those note
cards and write the problem down
and before you engage him
before you start picking at him or
yelling or starting to see as you're
starting to see red I want you to put
that card down on a table and I want you
to have the conversation about that
problem with him sitting next to you on
your side of the table
so you are both facing the quote-unquote
problem the issue okay and here's what
that's going to do you're gonna see a
cup that he left out overnight he's
gonna have like that little bit of
coffee left in the rim it's staying in
the cup and it's just gross and it's
gonna be sitting on the coffee table and
you're gonna see it
and you're gonna get insta-pissed
because that coffee cup means he doesn't
love you and he never listens to you and
he's disgusting and he's going to raise
kids who are slobs right you're Off to
the Races I want you to grab a note card
in that moment and write it down and
write down on that note card he left out
coffee cup comma he doesn't love me or
respect me
and I want you to set that on a table
and I want you to call him in
and then say hey
we need to talk about a problem you see
like how absurd this is and he's gonna
sit by you and you're gonna be like you
left a coffee mug out
and my body feels like you hate me
and y'all can both just stare together
shoulder by shoulder side by side at
this problem
and now I'm making fun of the problem
some of the problems may be big right
you don't come home when you say you're
going to
um you are you you pretend to be a
champion but you really are pretty
subversive about this thing I don't feel
safe around you you pressure me to do
things I don't want to do right so some
of these things may be real
but if we're in this relationship
together
remember this line
if you win and he loses you both lose
okay so going to war against him is not
going to help the relationship solving
these challenges that will pop up and by
the way these will pop up for the rest
of your relationship with him forever
and ever and ever amen until the end of
time
the goal is not to come up with a
challenge free or disagreement-free
relationship that's that's a boring way
to live that means neither of you are
trying very hard we've got to come up
with a way that we can always come back
to the table on the same side and solve
these things together does that make
sense yeah it makes perfect sense and
have the courage and the strength to say
I'm my wife has done this to me okay
I'll just give you some insight into my
house
she will get she'll see red on something
and I'll take it so personal and she
will look at me and not smile but kind
of smile and she will say John not
everything is about you
not all of my Smiles all of my happiness
is because of you and not all of my
anger is because of you not everything's
about you and he's gonna have to learn
that sometimes when you see red has
nothing to do with him
right and he's gonna have to learn to
not take things so personal in the same
way that you might have to learn to back
up thirty thousand feet detach a little
bit and realize hey we gotta there's a
there's a much longer game we're playing
here he's really tired he's exhausted he
didn't leave the cup out because he
hates me he left the cup out because man
what is going on in his life that's a
shift from judgment to curiosity
from anger and rage to hospitality
dude there's a wet towel in the middle
of the floor
it's because he's disgusting and gross
and I hate him or there's a wet towel on
the floor what in the world this
happened in his world where he just left
it there something must be going on one
of those is a shift to curiosity one of
those but again
put wet towel on that on that piece of
paper on that note card put it in the
desk and be like how do we solve this
one
and man you're gonna find that your most
of your problems most of the time
dissipate like a vapor and the real
challenge is the real relational issues
that pop up
you're gonna be able to look at them
side by side and say hey let's go tackle
these things together we'll be right
back
hey deloney here hey you know a while
back Society went off to rails and
people started to see sleep as like an
annoyance it's something in the way
right just chug another energy drink and
keep hustling and grinding my friends
sleep is not the enemy it's essential to
the way our minds and bodies function
and there are several things you can do
right away to start getting better sleep
first lay off the caffeine especially
after like 10 or 11 A.M and ditch the
screens at least an hour before bed and
I recommend getting a great mattress and
you can get a great mattress from my
friends at dreamcloud I speak from
experience here the right mattress can
make a huge difference in your sleep
quality it's why my family sleeps on
dream Cloud their mattresses are
designed to be soft and cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night and right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and 500
199 bucks in accessories when you use
promo code John deloney that's cooling
pillows luxury sheets and a mattress
protector so go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney today
all right we're back
um so back in 2021
a woman named Ruth called from Chicago
and she called to talk about her her
daughter had received a schizophrenia
diagnosis and she was calling to ask
about what she's what should she do what
happens next and she he has a follow-up
call here Ruth are you there
yes sir okay every time I get a
follow-up call I always they don't tell
me
what the follow-up call is and so you
could be calling to be like oh by the
way you completely screwed this up my
whole like whatever or it can be really
positive so tell me
um tell me uh what's going on
okay well I I was meaning to write you
for a couple of months now and I just
finally decided that I needed to write
that letter and give you an update
um your advice because our specific
question was that she wanted to share
her struggles and her possible diagnosis
with her friends and and kind of live
more openly with us she was feeling very
alone
and um her dad my husband and I were
really fearful about kind of the
exposure that that would give her
um especially since the diagnosis wasn't
formalized yet and um so your advice was
to to kind of work around that and give
her some more trusted adults at school
to talk to and
um some some Escape Routes if things
were bad at school so we did that she
had we called it the golden ticket and
she could leave class if she needed to
um she never even used it but like
having that ability to escape was kind
of comforting absolutely um did a
counselor and we brought them in on it
if I remember did y'all go get some more
some additional medical testing
um she's been doing medical tests for
over a year basically when we talked and
we had you know all of it laid out in
front of us blood work and MRIs and eegs
and pet scans and the whole thing and
schizophrenia is is a diagnosis of
exclusion you know you just check
everything else and then maybe that's
what you're left with
um and that's what we were really close
to and um like teenagers do sometimes we
made a plan and then she just did
something else
uh she went and told some friends of
hers
um and I found out about it she kept it
from us and it was a huge fight
um not my most composed moment as a
parent
um
it was it was really rough and I felt
very scared for her and it came out as
anger and that was bad
um can I hold on one sec
um
can I give you some peace there
you just said that better than I've
heard it articulated by almost anyone
I've ever talked to
we're scared for your daughter and it
came out as anger
for sure have you told her since then
that you're sorry
yeah yeah we we picked our
I never I never
never [__] I can hear it on you
um
it makes perfect sense that a child
wanted to reach out to some of their
peers and say hey
um I'm unique but I'm also just like
y'all and so that doesn't surprise me in
the least and wanting you you to really
protect your daughter and we don't know
what this is like and it's unknown let's
just be safe stay close to the cave that
makes sense too right and so
yeah you probably said some things and
yelled and screamed and kicked and
whatever like I I again hopefully he
didn't kick anybody but
um yeah you got mad and then you said
I'm sorry and I think that's a that's a
beautiful wave in your relationship so
good for you I want you to set that
brick down though man okay thank you
in front of him it was a
neuropsychologist and he said medically
the only thing that we're left with is
schizophrenia I said but I'm just not
comfortable with it he says it doesn't
match enough she's not experiencing any
of the other things that should be
affecting her life and her schoolwork
and her relationships
um and he sent us to one more Guy and
um pediatric neurologist who ran a test
we had already had but he ran it again
and he found something small that
doesn't usually have a lot of symptoms
with it he said try this medication and
we settled with medication for a while
and she is no longer being bothered by
her symptoms at all and I'm really
really grateful for those doctors so is
she having hallucinations and
what was she having
she was so so having visualization
no voices just seeing
okay so a distortion of her visual Fuel
and they didn't give up and I don't say
a schizophrenic diagnosis isn't medical
professionals giving up but your doctor
didn't take the easy route didn't just
do 15 minutes of okay it looks like this
here's some medication the rest of your
life they said I want to keep digging
because something doesn't add up good
for you good for your doctors that makes
me that gives me restores my faith in
the whole system yeah that's so good and
I wanted to get to kick that back to you
because you had told me the same thing
you know just keep asking keep fighting
um this may be where you end up but it
doesn't have to be and and you can keep
working for that so it was nice to have
a little incredible and what what a
blessing I know people um
really thumbnails at medication what an
Incredible Gift and yes we are people
are way over Medicaid all the blah blah
blah but what an Incredible Gift that we
live in a sliver of History where there
is a medication for this particular
thing
right that gives you your daughter her
life back that's amazing so good yeah
well dude it was really important for me
to kind of just focus on the positive
for a couple of minutes and write that
letter to you it's it's been really bad
at our house on some other friends so
yeah I wanted to to be grateful for that
well thank you thank you so they said
you have another question
um I don't I don't know if it's really a
question I just um the reason it's been
so bad and the reason I was up late at
night writing this letter
um is that my husband was killed in a
car accident two months ago oh good God
Ruth
yeah so what happened
single vehicle no fault
from work
I'm so sorry
thank you
so um
yeah
I don't know that there's a question
that encapsulates that um you don't need
to ask a question every day I just know
I'm sitting with you the next thing yeah
I mean that's I mean what else are you
gonna do right
nothing it
what was his name
you don't say it it's okay will you tell
me something great about him
he was so much more than the breadwinner
he was
the sole income for the house and so
that's really scary to face going
forward but it's all of the other things
because everything is so much quieter he
was
the one who made us laugh and he was the
one who told us it would be okay
wouldn't it and we believed him and
he was the one who fixed everything when
it was broken so
it's just really different
I have five children 17 down to seven so
oh man
it's
it's really bizarre for me to try to
navigate
just myself but I'm also navigating for
five other people to you know try to
help them process that and it's
it's a lot but I don't know that there's
a lot of processing that you can help
with
yeah
I want you to relieve yourself of that
that's a heavy heavy burden
right
um
your focus is being with
mm-hmm
that makes sense
and I know it's easy for you as as a
parent of five kids to get caught up in
just the
I gotta put that away because these kids
gotta eat and these kids got to get to
school and these kids I gotta keep that
air conditioner running and the heater
going or whatever
um
but if you haven't
honor him
honor yourself and honor your kids by
letting them see you hurt too
yeah yeah we're trying and that that
certainly happens okay
um are you are you back
or is this still a fuzzy foggy dream and
you roll over and he's still there but
he's not no it's it's horribly real okay
who's walking with you during this
season
um we have some good
good support from extended family and
from our church family and a lot of
people looking out for us in a lot of
ways and we're just
everybody takes a piece of the puzzle
and hopefully it it comes together
somehow
that's a very evasive answer
let me ask you this way and and I want
to protect you I know I know I know
do you have two or three or four women
that you can text and call 24 hours a
day three 165 days a year and say I need
you to come get his shoes out of the
house
I need you to come over to my house
right now because I just need someone to
hold my hand and lay here by me
yeah you have that okay good do you
promise that you'll you'll lean on them
yes okay I'm gonna tell you something
hard to hear
okay
um this will get heavier before it gets
lighter
okay
there's this sense that we're over the
hump this is the way this is and then
we're just gonna plow through what comes
next and this it comes in waves
okay
and
is not any contrary to popular belief
there's not a lot you can do to fortify
yourself for the big wave right what you
can do is surround yourself with people
who will hold your arms up and hold you
above water when they hit
and they will hit
okay
and I'm not telling you that to be to be
a jerk I'm telling that because I love
you
no it just is
um
so yeah I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry
thank you and for what it's worth it
and those nights where I stood there and
just stared at the ceiling and said I
can't do this I just decided to write
about something good that turned out
right so that's where it got us here
that's awesome well thank you for
honoring me
um
I'm telling your story and thank you for
honoring your husband sounds like he's
an amazing guy
um
honoring his story say say a couple of
those things so I'm thinking about just
a dad driving home from work today
um
who's kind of like
it's suddenly going to be snapped back
into reality that they've actually had
the privilege to drive home today
I hope so what are what are some things
your husband brought to you sound like
he brought light and he brought joy and
he brought laughter what are some give
me two or three things that he brought
to your home
that you you want to communicate to
other knuckleheaded guys out there
driving home with their dead-eyed loose
and Tire on their neck
he he laughed in insatiably and he
laughed at everything and and that sound
is missing now and we miss it terribly
and
you know your your wife maybe rolls her
eyes and says oh you're such a child but
you bring something when you bring
laughter
um
and it's it's okay you can tell fart
jokes with your third grader
thank God because otherwise I would be
in a mess I know I know your wife rolls
her eyes but it's okay almost out of the
back of her head sometimes can I tell
you this too
um if no one's told you this there's
gonna come a moment if it hasn't
happened already When You're gonna laugh
really really hard
about something
and then you're gonna feel guilty about
it
you're gonna have a good morning when
you get the kids all off to school and
nobody breaks down and even some of the
younger ones help with the other kids
lunches and it just kind of happens
and all of a sudden you're gonna realize
that
this is life moving forward
and then you're going to feel guilty
you're going to feel sick about moving
forward and I want you to know that
that's a normal part of the process and
you're not screwed up and you're not
broken and
it's okay to feel Joy again and it's
okay to laugh again and it's okay to be
laughing and then all of a sudden start
crying all the same time and it's it's
okay to have a bunch of people over and
then five minutes in you're like
everybody out everybody out not today oh
that's okay
yeah we sat down the morning after my
kids and I and we said when none of us
know what we're doing and so good we
just wrote new rules and they're they're
literally on a piece of loose leaf taped
to one of the doors of our house so good
and then hey once a month ride them
again
you can be okay and you can be not okay
either one's fine it's like yeah
yes yes yes yes do you have a you have a
group have you sat down with a group of
do you meet with anybody who has lost
people
lost somebody there's a there's a grief
group through our church and then
there's a family counselor that's
meeting with us twice a week you're
amazing Ruth
if I can help you in any way along the
journey let me know okay okay I'm gonna
send you stay on the line and I'm gonna
send you every single deck of questions
for humans I got
about families and kids and all that so
that way when it gets quiet in the house
some there's always gonna be a deck
laying around that you can pull up and
be like all right and you can pull
something up okay
I'll give it a go that's I don't know if
it's gonna help at all I'm just trying
to think of something I can I can leave
you with add a little bit of joy into
into your home but it's just gonna be
it's gonna be a shout out hey I had a
guy let himself into my house and leave
casseroles in the fridge so uh deck of
cards I'll take it I mean yeah that's
look that's creepy on top of weird
he's a good guy we should put us on your
front door that's like I like your food
please don't break in I'll kill you
that'd probably be good
that that's a perfect example of gosh
sometimes men try to help and what are
you doing what are you doing
it's all right it is but it's super not
don't break into
golly
Hi man hey we love you Ruth and anything
we can do um please don't hesitate to
let us know
[Music]
I'm sorry
I'm heartbroken with you
and
[Music]
I'll be right back
hey good folks John deloney here I feel
like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
ask John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
we did a Valentine's week last week that
was about relationships and marriage and
sex intimacy all that and some of the
calls that we got during sex and
intimacy and relationship week for
Valentine's Day we had Hearts like
flying around on the screen behind us
some of the calls got really heavy they
were hard calls um but they were very
important calls and so we didn't end up
using them in the Valentine's episodes
because we were going for a very
specific ethos right a very specific
tone
but I also didn't want to lose the call
I didn't want to lose the moment that I
was able to share that somebody honored
me with sharing with them and
um man a couple of these calls
we get questions about this stuff all
the time so they're going to help a
whole lot of folks so this is one of
those calls you're gonna see like I said
you're gonna see hearts flying around
it's gonna be like what is happening I'm
wearing different shirt right if you're
watching this whole episode if you're
listening to it you won't know any
different but
um I really thought this was an
important call so I want you to check
this out
let's go to Ryan in Phoenix Arizona
what's up Ryan
hey how are you thanks for taking my
call today you got it man what's up
so let me give you a little back story
here
um
been married for almost 14 years uh
married kind of young at 22.
um so it's just kind of the culture of
where we grew up and religion and the
expectation is you get married young you
start having kids right
and I tried calling off the engagement
and didn't feel like it was right still
wanted to date more
and was convinced partially that maybe
it was just anxiety that I should still
go through with it that led up to kind
of the wedding day
and even at the altar you know where
we're getting married I wanted to say no
I knew that it wasn't right
and so you know with these thoughts and
these feelings so I've been struggling
with
feelings of regret
um second guessing pretty much our
entire marriage which has led to kind of
one foot in one foot out
um never really fully committed a
hundred percent and
recently led to a I I feel like this
kind of led to a recent Affair that I
had
um and so I'm really struggling right
now with this thought process do I stay
do I go
she wants to make this work
um
why would she want to be married to
somebody who has resented her for 15
years 14 years
that is a very good question I don't
know and I've asked for that
so I
why is she the wrong person
and I want you to articulate it very
specifically and don't BS me like why is
she the wrong person
I've always been attracted to other
women more than her okay so say that in
a way that is not a circling passive
aggressive way you're not attracted to
your wife
um I don't know how to word that just
yes or no man
yeah yeah yeah that's what it comes down
to okay
um what about her do you not find
attractive
um she was just no or hasn't ever really
just been my
tight if that's even a thing and I I
struggle staying this out loud I know
that's why I'm that's why I'm asking you
to do it because I wanna I want to get
out of you live your whole existence is
in your feelings
sure and it's the articulation of some
of these things that really turns the
lights on the feelings
because feelings aren't are terrible GPS
directors they're fantastic indicators
of wreck car wreck ahead you need to
exit here but they're terrible
um forgiving directions
and your whole life is run by feelings
that's why I'm pushing you I want you to
articulate very specifically
because let's I'll just throw something
out there okay and I know I'm making it
uncomfortable I know it's hard what I'm
asking you today yeah
um let's say your wife is uh you don't
find her pretty because you think she's
overweight and you have always been
attracted to someone who um is not
overweight or in your mind isn't
overweight and
you fixate on her weight and you lean in
on hey what about this or what if we ate
like this and what if we did this or
whatever or there's some physical
feature of hers it's just not like I
just think other people are whatever
that is
feeling after feeling after feeling
after feeling after feeling
and so I want you to own here's a big
shift you need you've got to make
you you're talking with what I call
distance language this led to this which
led to this which led to me having an
affair I call bullcrap on that
you did have somebody that you felt all
along I shouldn't be marrying I
shouldn't be marrying and you married
them that happens that happens yeah and
then every day for 14 years you've
chosen to be miserable
that is a conscious daily choice you
have made
you consciously chose to sleep with
somebody that wasn't your wife nothing
led to another thing you chose that and
I want you the reason I'm saying that
directly I want you to own it because
that's the only way you can then take
ownership of what happens next
because you're gonna be the guy that's
like is gonna slowly Drown Your Wife
until she finally gets the courage to
leave you because you haven't had the
courage to you see what I'm saying
yeah or the courage to say
after 14 years I've been lying to you I
actually am not attracted to you in this
way or I I think you're beautiful and I
think you're wonderful I'm actually
attracted to her too or her also or to
other women too right does that make
sense it's so yeah there's something
about saying things out loud and
truthful even when they hurt and are
awful and make you sound like a complete
and total ass which I think you can be
right so it's all of that and together
but you're living in this mushy emotive
feeling world and usually if you listen
to the show I'm having to take big tough
guys and get them to sit in the
emotional feeling world you're the
opposite man you got to get up and face
reality
yeah that makes sense
yeah and so okay so you you let's let's
I I don't think it's true but let's
let's go with it I'm gonna trust you you
made a mistake getting married right
yeah and you're married
why have you chosen misery for 14 years
good question I feel
there you go I don't care about your
feelings why have you chosen
I am a people pleaser at heart excellent
and I don't like ruffling feathers and I
do that to the detriment of myself
you do that to the detriment of your
kids and to the detriment of your wife
yes and your faith community does that
make sense
yeah
um
can you think back to moments when y'all
were in sync and connected
yeah I I think back and I I've thought
about this my entire marriage hasn't
been a complete sham I've been
happy we've had happy moments
um
and I I have a hard time sparsing out
what was different then
versus now knowing that I've always had
these underlying thoughts and regrets
is it gonna sound so crazy but I don't
think you have
hmm
um as the great brene Brown says which
you go looking for you're sure to find
sure tell me about this affair where'd
you meet this person
work yeah and how was it
exciting yeah honestly what it was
exciting and
it fulfilled
desires that I've had for a long time
okay about being with somebody that I
was more attracted to
what was beneath that attraction
what do you mean
tell me if I'm off
you've been being told what to do your
whole freaking life
yeah and you've been writing through
life on other people's train tracks your
entire life
yeah and somebody else essentially
picked out your wife for you somebody
picked up the life for you they picked
out your church they picked up the
building they picked out the little
white picket fence around the house you
were going to live in
somebody else picked out the clothes
that your kids are going to wear they
picked out the schools they're going to
go to everybody's picked out your life
for you
and I think you have taken all of that
frustration in really what it is it's
rage
and you've put that on your wife
and then somebody comes along and yes
beautiful beautiful co-workers sexy
co-worker laughs at your jokes all those
things
maybe does things in bed that your wife
won't do like all that stuff
but beneath that
is somebody looking you in the eye and
saying you're freaking Ryan you can do
anything
and for the first time in 14 years
probably 30 years you felt alive
am I right or wrong
no you're right and are you still with
that person
with the affair
no did the air run out of that real
quick
no
um I actually changed the jobs okay
um
but if I'm being honest I would love to
go back okay
yeah
have you given up on your marriage and
that's a that's a question you've got to
answer honestly because if you're out of
your marriage dude have the courage to
stop dragging your wife behind a moving
car it's cruel man
I agree I agree
and that's that's where I have these
huge
conflicting arguments in my brain every
single day it's a real real simple
argument it is there's not conflicting
back and forth I am going to never call
that woman again yes she's sexy yes
she's beautiful yes we had a wild fun
time and I felt alive
but it was cancer
I am gonna never call her again when she
when pictures of her naked body pop in
my mind or things we were doing together
when that pops my mind I'm gonna
intentionally choose to not think about
I'm gonna have another thought ready to
go
and I will double down every inch of my
every second of my life will be
committed to my wife moving forward
we're gonna make this thing work
it's that
or it's I'm out
and both of them take bravery and you
haven't displayed that yet
no
no because I'm afraid to yeah and you
should be and I'm gonna tell you this
one thousand percent
and the people in the YouTube comments
bro don't read them because they're
going to be mean to you or they're going
to be like you just live your own life
YOLO or whatever
right what's going to happen is you're
gonna go leave your wife move into an
apartment you got kids too
three okay you're gonna leave your three
kids you're gonna leave your wife and
you're gonna move into apartment
and you're gonna have that Hollow
feeling but this other girl is going to
come over for a season
and then you're gonna realize One Day
You're Gonna Roll over when she spends
the night
and you're gonna catch a glimpse of
yourself in the mirror and you're gonna
realize you went with you to that new
bed
yeah and you don't like Ryan you never
have
yeah
and so you're trapped trying to get
somebody else to make you feel worthy
and you found somebody at work man you
found somebody that made you feel
valuable and alive and excited all those
things
I believe with all my guts any couple
any couple can reclaim that in their
marriage if they both decide to and make
no mistake your wife's gonna participate
in this too
yeah right but she can't participate in
something that you haven't been honest
about
or that you him hot about or you've been
like man I just can we like spice some
things up and she's like I I don't
really know what that means you're like
well you know I need you to do these
things so that I feel alive
yeah or this particular sex act makes me
feel alive or we go away for the weekend
or when you do this with the kids it
makes me feel dead inside can we try
something else
and that starts with you being brave not
blaming her for not doing stuff does
that make sense
yeah yeah that makes sense
so what are you gonna do
I don't know
and that's uh honestly that's where I'm
struggling the most is knowing what to
do she wants to make it work does she
know you cheated on her
she knows yeah
where you've been in counseling and
therapy
um
she would not still be wanting to make
it work if you've been honest in therapy
and you haven't been
okay have you
no I I feel like I have been
yeah you've told her you're not
attracted to her and why
I I have told her all of the reasons
um and she still wants to make this work
and so you know I'm filled with guilt
I'm filled with shame I'm filled with
regret and
you know making one decision one way or
the other I'm afraid that if I make a
decision will I continue to regret and
then have even more regret on top of
regret if I make the wrong decision
and so we're we've been stuck in this
holding pattern of going to therapy and
talking and her knowing that I'm still
on the fence of not sure what to do and
it's cruel
um yeah I agree I I feel like I am
holding her hostage you're holding
yourself hostage
[Music]
um
yeah you
here's what I here's what I think you
tell me I'm crazy
I think you love this woman that you're
married to
and I think like all marriages she's not
perfect and you're not either
yeah and I think you think so little of
yourself
and saying your needs out loud and
saying dreams of yours out loud and
going and actually getting out of your
own freaking head and doing doing acting
making moves in your life in your career
as a dad as a husband as a lover like
getting after it instead of just sitting
there and stewing in these
and these loopty loop-de-loopty Loops
man
and I think you've cast all of your
feelings of depression all your feelings
of sadness and of well you know life
you've dumped all of that on your wife
because you were unsure of the marriage
in the first place I believe you on that
you're unsure of it ABS 100 absolutely
but I think the question you've got to
ask yourself is
what choice am I going to make moving
forward and
dude
you can't just sit there stood up man
you got to make a call because you're
drowning you're teaching your kids this
is what love looks like this is what a a
wife this is how you this is how you
value and love her
this is what being a decisive dad looks
like a co-parent and a co-creator of a
home looks like man they're worth more
than that you are too
I think though until you decide that
you're worth being well and you get
whole you're going to continue on this
loop-de-loop man and I promise you
you're gonna if you leave your wife and
go to this other person you're gonna
it's gonna be several months
before either she leaves you and you get
into one of these Loop tube I don't know
what we want for dinner and I don't I'm
just gonna start looping on you or
um
you're gonna realize oh crap I went with
me
I hate that you're in this position man
um it's an it's it's you've got to start
taking ownership right now
right now
here's the choices I've made up to now
I've chosen misery I've chosen
dishonesty I've chosen infidelity and
you can also choose
to completely hit control or delete and
become a different person you can choose
that today
or you can choose to be the guy that
left his wife and kids for the woman to
work you could choose that too but for
God's sakes make a choice
[Music]
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are I don't know why I
always come back in like that like I'm
in some kind of metal band so we're back
and we wrap up today's show one of my
favorite bands of all time I still
remember back in high school when their
kerplunk record came out
followed by the Smash Hit album titled
dookie you knew I was gonna love this
band it's Green Day this one is called
basket case and it goes like this
do you have the time to listen to me
whine about nothing and everything all
at once I'm one of those melodramatic
fools neurotic to the bone no doubt
about it and sometimes I give myself the
creeps and sometimes my mind plays
tricks on me
it all keeps adding up but I think I'm
cracking up am I paranoid or as Kelly
often asks am I just stoned
I don't know we'll see you soon